[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más de euros abrimos entonces
esta revista de prensa con un caso que
resuena hoy en día en distintos ámbitos
es que se cumplen 50 años nada menos del
caso watergate y el washington post el
periódico que está puesta escándalo
publica una editorial sobre este
aniversario
buenos días raúl exactamente breve
contexto es que el 17 de junio de
1972 tuvo lugar el robo en el complejo
watergate que era usado por el partido
demócrata de eeuu como su sede de
campaña de cara a las elecciones de
noviembre de ese mismo año bien tuvo
lugar ese robo que para muchos pasó
desapercibido pero para un equipo de
periodistas del washington post pues
desató no mucha intriga y una
investigación que acabó revelando que
detrás de ese suceso pues había toda una
operación de espionaje por parte de la
casa blanca de nixon a la partido
demócrata bien lo que hace precisamente
el 'washington post' recordamos pues el
medio donde tuvo lugar esta
investigación es comparar la situación
de ese momento con la situación en la
que se encuentra eeuu cincuenta años más
tarde dice que ese caso y más que nada
la investigación a que desató fue
determinante para la historia política
moderna de eeuu dice la administración
nixon abusó de su poder pero el
parlamento y la prensa investigaron la
ciudadanía se informó y se posicionó
incluso la élite del partido republicano
acabó forzando la renuncia de nixon en
1974 recordemos pero dice que cuando
traslada esta situación a la actualidad
particularmente en el marco de la
investigación en el capitolio sobre los
hechos del 6 de enero de 2021 en los que
recordemos este panel del congreso que
investiga el asalto al capitolio declaró
que el expresidente donald trump alentó
un intento de golpe de estado dice en
este caso la diferencia es que la
mayoría de los miembros del partido
republicano tienen miedo a pronunciar
una palabra contra el ex presidente de
donald trump
en el partido en sus garras dice peor la
mayoría se niega a comprometerse con la
búsqueda de la verdad ni a darle
importancia dice si al pueblo
estadounidense le importo hace 50 años
que el gobierno se rompiera y pues todos
los esfuerzos necesarios para volver a
que las instituciones pues digamos
siguieran su caudal democrático es hora
de hacerlo hoy en día también recordemos
que el 'washington post' adoptó en 2017
precisamente una frase que aparentemente
usaba bob woodward uno de los
periodistas junto a carl bernstein
digamos que llevó adelante esta
investigación que es la de democracy
days in that in darkness no la
democracia muere en la oscuridad una
frase pues hollywoodiense pero pero pues
cierta que nos recuerda digamos la
importancia de la prensa libre e
independiente pues para el buen
funcionamiento de la democracia tal y
como señala nuestro compañero álvaro
cordero en su crónica de historia que
esta semana dedicó precisamente al caso
watergate y que pueden consultar para
profundizar en este tema en la web de
france 24 punto com o también en youtube
y no nos vamos a perder los hablando
está importa de la libertad de prensa
hoy hay un nuevo avance en el caso del
periodista australiano julian assange
que supone para muchos un retroceso en
la libertad de expresión y también en
derecho a la información después de que
la secretaria del interior del reino
unido- brito para tele aceptar entonces
firmar esta orden de extradición de
assange a la unión americana exactamente
no raúl estas casualidades históricas si
es que existen las casualidades como
siempre decimos y es que wikileaks se
dice es un día oscuro para la libertad
de prensa y la democracia británica
precisamente porque eeuu bueno él julian
assange se convertiría en el primer
editor en el primer periodista
encarcelado en eeuu por la información
que publicó porque recordemos que
wikileaks publicó pues distintos
documentos clasificados hasta ese
momento que revelaban supuestos crímenes
de guerra cometidos por el ejército
estadounidense en irak y afganistán
entre otras guerras pero solamente
recordar que en esta en este mismo
programa baltasar garzón que coordina la
defensa internacional de julian assange
porque consideran que es julian assange
sufre una persecución política por parte
de los servicios de inteligencia de eeuu
y porque no tendría un juicio justo en
ese país de ser extraditado también nos
dijo que agotarían todas las instancias
judiciales en reino unido e incluso
irían a si es necesario al tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos también
pueden recuperar esta entrevista en
nuestra página web pues si les interesa
el caso así es los y precisamente esa
semana el 'new york times' publicó
imágenes inéditas ya está cambiando de
tema de la prisión de guantánamo
ampliamente criticada por ser base de
encarcelamiento de prisioneros de guerra
sin cargos ni juicios exactamente y no
deja de tener la relación en este tema
pues también con wikileaks porque como
nos recuerda la periodista del new york
times' desde que abrieron esta base
militar en una cuba está en esa base de
encarcelamiento perdón en cuba eeuu
guantánamo no que simboliza tanto la
guerra contra el terror desatada tras el
atentado contra las torres gemelas el 11
de septiembre de 2001 eeuu ha mantenido
un fuerte control sobre la información
que se publicaba no ese centro
penitenciario sin embargo en 2011
wikileaks publicó imágenes clasificadas
hasta ese momento en que sorprendieron a
impactaron al mundo por las condiciones
de encarcelamiento pero también ahora el
'new york times' gracias precisamente a
la freedom information act a una tutela
que impuso y por eso también relación
con la libertad de prensa y con el
derecho a la información ha obtenido
distintas fotografías de los primeros
años de apertura de guantánamo
fotografías que fueron tomadas por
fotógrafos militares destinadas pues a
las autoridades estadounidenses y que
pueden ustedes consultar en el 'new york
times' que son realmente muy impactante
y cerramos en colombia' exactamente
porque tampoco deja de tener relación
pues con el derecho a la información por
parte de los ciudadanos esta ausencia
del debate electoral de cara a la
segunda vuelta recordemos que el
candidato rodolfo hernández desde antes
de la primera vuelta se había negado a
participar en los últimos debates
presidenciales y finalmente también
continuó negándose ya cuando fue elegido
para pasar al balotaje
al izquierdista gustavo petro que nunca
se ha negado a participar de ningún
k'ara k'ara pero finalmente un tribunal
de bogotá dijo que obligaba a los
candidatos a enfrentarse en un debate
electoral rodolfo hernández ayer pareció
que cedía a pesar de imponernos
distintas condiciones que
radiotelevisión colombia aceptó pero que
finalmente pues no acabaron de
materializarse y parece pues que la
ciudadanía de colombia va a quedarse no
tiene este derecho a ver a los dos
candidatos a la presidencia del país
pues contraponer a sus ideas y después
sus planes para el futuro de colombia
rosas gracias como siempre por toda la
información de esa revista de prensa nos
vemos el lunes con más información vamos
a ampliarse seguramente de este tema
seguramente nos vamos a ampliar con
nuestro primer invitado el día rosa
gracias